حسنًا ، نحن نسمع الآن من أحد
مسلمي الروهينجا الذي أمضى أكثر من
شهر ينجرف في البحر في قارب محطم
بدون طعام ولا ماء ولا دواء
في جميع اللاجئين البالغ عددهم 200 لاجئ الذين فروا من
مخيماتهم في بنغلاديش في أواخر نوفمبر
بحثًا عن  حياة أفضل بينما في عام 2000
لم تنجو بولا هانكوكس من سي إن إن ،
تقريرنا وتحذيرنا من الصور
التي توشك على رؤيتها مزعجة
والرسم الصيفي
لكل وجه واحدًا تلو الآخر
ينهارون أجسادًا هزيلة تمسك
بأطفال صغار وآخرون بلا حراك على
ما يبدو فاقدًا للوعي على أندونيسي
الشاطئ هم لاجئو الروهينجا الذين
تركوا للانجراف على متن قارب في البحر المفتوح
منسيين وتجاهلوا مأساة
إنسانية لا تزال تكرر نفسها.
في
غضون ثلاثة أيام فقط من الإمداد بالطعام
والماء ، يكاد يتعذر التعرف على ما
حدث عندما ركبت القارب
وأخبرتني أنه لا يوجد طعام ولا
دواء ولا ماء  طوال تلك الأيام
فقط عندما تمطر ، هل يمكننا شرب
مياه الأمطار بعد أيام قليلة من الرحلة
، وتقول إن المحرك تعطل ، لقد
تقطعت بهم السبل في بحر أندامان ، تتذكر باتا مانيسا
مشاهدة طفلة تموت بعد
شرب الماء المالح ، وتقول إن
سائق القارب قفز  في البحر في اليأس
من العطش والجوع وتوفي
تاركًا حمولته البشرية اليائسة تنجرف
بلا حول ولا قوة على أمل الإنقاذ في 18 ديسمبر بعد
أكثر من ثلاثة أسابيع من
الإبحار ، تمكن شقيق آدم ونساء في
بنغلاديش من الاتصال بالقارب في
محاولة لتنظيم عملية إنقاذ من أحد السكان المحليين.
تقول وكالة اللاجئين التابعة للأمم المتحدة إن 26 شخصًا
لقوا حتفهم قبل أن يتم إنقاذ القارب من قبل
الصيادين الإندونيسيين والسلطات المحلية
، وتقول الوكالة إن عدة
دول قد غضت الطرف عن القارب في إندونيسيا.  لأننا نتواصل
من دول إلى دول
في المنطقة أينما كنا نتلقى
تقارير تفيد بأن هذا إما قريب من انقلاب واحد
لم يتصرف أحد بناءً على تلك
الطلبات والنداءات عديمي الجنسية
واضطهدوا هؤلاء كانوا من اللاجئين الهينغا
ولم يعرفوا سوى القليل من السلام بعد أن فروا مرة
واحدة للنجاة بحياتهم قبل خمس سنوات في
ميانمار بعد حملة وحشية من
قتل حريق عمد من قبل الجيش إلى
بنغلاديش  في مخيم لطيف مترامي الأطراف للاجئين ،
كوكس بازار مع القليل من الأمل في
الحياة فقط البقاء على قيد الحياة
في بنغلاديش ، كانت حياتنا صعبة ،
فقد مُنعنا من الخروج للبحث عن
عمل ، حيث لم يتمكن الأطفال من الذهاب إلى المدرسة
هذا العام ، مما يهدد بأن يصبح أحد
أكثر الأمراض فتكًا بالنسبة لهم.  تقول منظمة الروهينجا في
مدن شرق آسيا ووترز ، المفوضية السامية للأمم المتحدة لشؤون اللاجئين ، إن
ثلاثة قوارب على الأقل تم إنقاذها في
ديسمبر من قبل البحرية السريلانكية ،
وانتهى بها المطاف في إندونيسيا ، لكن قاربًا واحدًا
يحمل 180 شخصًا لم يسمع
عنه منذ بداية ديسمبر / كانون الأول ،
خشى ركابه من فقدان هؤلاء.  هي
حرفيا أفخاخ الموت التي بمجرد أن
تدخل فيها أه ينتهي بك الأمر تفقد
حياتك وهذا يتم أه من قبل
المهربين والمهربين البشر الذين لا يرحمون
أولئك الذين لا يهتمون
بحياة البشر يكلفون حوالي ألف
دولار مقابل وعد كاذب
برحلة لمدة سبعة أيام إلى ماليزيا ، وهو ثمن باهظ للغاية لدرجة
أنها اضطرت إلى ترك ابنتها البالغة من العمر سبع
سنوات خلفها مع والدتها في
بنغلاديش على افتراض أنها  سوف ينضمون لاحقًا
، يجب عليهم إحضار ابنتي الأخرى إلي
، وتقول إن قلبي يحترق من أجلها ، وكل
ما أردته هو الحصول على
التعليم لأولادي ، وهي الآن تواجه
عذاب العيش بعيدًا عن طفل
أثناء التعامل مع صدمة أخرى من
باولا  روح سي إن إن هانكوك